good morning everyone my name is
Giovanni modelo and I'm the global
editor-in-chief former German Mirjam at
least part of the financial time troupe
good morning tiago i'm here at the World
Economic Forum in Rio so I'm here to
answer a question what keeps you
motivated well I am motivated all the
time I look at all the challenges at
work all the challenges in life and I
try to every day to set different goal I
try to see if I can do something better
if I can improve the people i manage if
I can improve myself as a journalist so
that is something that keeps me
motivated I don't need anyone to tell me
what to do because i already have this
firing myself